[Música]
Joe biden se reunirá este lunes con el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy para
avanzar en la negociación sobre el techo
de la deuda demócratas y republicanos
están lejos del acuerdo mientras se
acerca el 1 de junio la fecha límite
impuesta por el tesoro
[Música]
Ecuador está a la espera de que el
Consejo Nacional electoral Determine una
fecha para las elecciones anticipadas
desatadas por la muerte Cruzada
decretada por el presidente Guillermo
lasso Tenemos reporte desde quito
avanza la búsqueda en Colombia de los
cuatro menores desaparecidos tras un
accidente de avioneta el pasado 1 de
Mayo en la selva amazónica grupos
indígenas de todo el país se suman a la
llamada operación Esperanza ampliamos
desde el terreno
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
maceu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
Y empezamos en Estados Unidos donde hay
expectativa ante los posibles avances
que haya este lunes en torno al tema que
tiene en vilo al país se trata del techo
de la deuda se espera que en la tarde el
presidente Joe biden se vuelva a reunir
con el líder de la cámara de
representantes el republicano Kevin
mccarthy para avanzar en las
negociaciones sobre el límite del gasto
público Y es que tras varias reuniones
republicanos y demócratas no logran un
acuerdo a pesar de las advertencias del
departamento del tesoro que estima que
el 1 de junio el país entraría en
situación de impago
estoy viendo En dónde están nuestras
diferencias y Cómo podemos resolverlas
sentí que esa parte fue productiva pero
mira no hay acuerdo todavía estamos
separados el acuerdo será cuando
volvamos a unir a nuestros equipos para
que entendamos claramente de lo que
estamos hablando de lo que se está
hablando informarle al presidente y
luego dejarlo dormir un poco quería
reunirse personalmente mañana acepte eso
dije que lo haríamos en algún momento de
la tarde
cambiamos de información porque en El
Salvador 12 personas murieron durante
una estampida en un partido de fútbol el
ministro de gobernación señaló que hubo
sobreventa de entradas aunque las
investigaciones continúan en marcha el
informe es de Max Pérez Gallardo
tragedia en el Cuscatlán en San Salvador
capital salvadoreña al menos una decena
de personas perdieron la vida resultado
de una estampida humana dentro del
estadio Cuscatlán se jugaba el partido
de vuelta de cuartos de final entre
Alianza y el club deportivo faz cuando
cientos de personas saltaron de las
gradas al campo escapando de la asfixia
provocada por la multitud de la sección
general de la tribuna hubo una el portón
no votaron
lastimosamente habían niños ancianos
ellos fueron los perjudicados y dos
veces hay gente que que se le ha dado
primeros auxilios y
los mayores responsables ahorita son la
autoridad las autoridades del país
centroamericano atribuyen el suceso a la
falta de organización y a la sobreventa
de boletos también es repudiable que las
personas encargadas de estos escenarios
de las ventas de boletos no tengan el
control estricto
aficionados han demostrado que les
vendieron boletos falsos
y les permitieron la entrada otros
hablan de que se de que hubo sobreventa
en el mercado negro y como haya sido el
caso el punto es de que terminó en una
tragedia el presidente del Salvador
nayib bukele se pronunció a través de su
perfil de Twitter remarcando que su
gobierno inició Las investigaciones y
que los culpables de la tragedia no
quedarían impunes la federación de
fútbol salvadoreña lamentó los sucesos y
anunció la suspensión del torneo
nacional
y el único mandatario latinoamericano
que asistió al g7 el presidente de
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
explicó que fue vódimirse lensky No
asistió a la cita que tenían acordada a
pesar de que el jefe de estado ucraniano
reiteró en varias ocasiones su voluntad
de acercarse a los países de América
Latina además Lula declaró de nuevo que
ve lejos el fin de la guerra
sólo es posible hablar de paz cuando se
lensky Putin quieran hablar de paz
no es posible construir una propuesta en
guerra
lo que queremos es que primero pare en
la guerra paren los ataques y luego
trataremos de dialogar para encontrar
una salida negociada para Ucrania y
Rusia eso es lo que queremos es posible
que usted construya un plan desde afuera
hacia adentro
son Ucrania y Rusia los que necesitan
querer un modelo de paz
y continuamos en Ecuador que cierra una
semana muy convulsa la espera de que el
próximo miércoles el Consejo Nacional
electoral Determine una fecha definitiva
para las elecciones anticipadas desde
quito nuestro enviado especial Rodrigo
sedano con la información
Ecuador vive su semana política más
convulsa en los últimos dos años que han
estado marcados por una dura lucha
política entre la presidencia de la
República liderada por el presidente
Guillermo lasso y la oposición dentro de
la asamblea nacional una asamblea que
cerró esta semana el presidente lasso
tras decretar la muerte Cruzada durante
el juicio político en su contra por
presunto delito de peculado así con
cierta tensa calma han vivido los
Ecuatorianos esta semana
hay una
relativa primeramente porque no ha
habido más infestaciones
esperemos que de esto llegue ya cuando
se termine cuando ya haya las próximas
elecciones si se pidió el congreso es
como que no ha habido ni no ha habido
congreso no ha habido nada Así es como
que tuviéramos no estuviéramos ahorita
ni presidente no estuvimos no tenemos
ahorita presidente Pero qué toca
nosotros toca luchar seguir adelante
porque el país en el país que estamos es
duro duro está ahorita el Ecuador tras
este cierre del Congreso se convocaron
elecciones extraordinarias ahora será el
Consejo Nacional electoral el que vete
va a dar una fecha fija tentativamente
serán entre el 20 y el 22 de agosto de
este mismo año una selección es para las
que Aparentemente el correísmo llega con
ventaja tras haber ganado las últimas
municipales Solamente los que salieron
están buscando la forma de volver a
ingresar donde que sacan plata súper
facilito y de una forma Casi casi gratis
solamente ganan gente oportunista gente
que se aprovecha de la cultura de la
gente de los de la gente que necesita
es una decepción terrible que tenemos
ahorita actualmente en a nivel político
una vez el presidente Guillermo lasso ha
declarado que no se presentará estos
comicios ahora el juego político ha
habido hacia el interior de los partidos
y de las coaliciones electorales que
buscarán a los mejores candidatos para
ser el próximo presidente de la
república
y cerramos en Colombia donde continúa la
búsqueda de cuatro niños desaparecidos
tras el accidente de una avioneta en la
selva amazónica y a las fuerzas armadas
se unen distintas comunidades indígenas
conocedoras del territorio nuestros
enviados especiales a la zona tienen el
reporte
estamos en San José del guaviare detrás
de mí está la brigada de la selva del
ejército nacional desde donde se está
gestionando todo el operativo de rescate
de los cuatro niños perdidos en la selva
pero en este operativo no solo
participan fuerzas armadas también hay
indígenas de la zona de otros puntos de
Colombia y también del lugar de origen
de los niños perdidos Harvey Gómez llegó
hasta San José del guaviare para
participar en las labores de rescate y
fue uno de los que encontró la avioneta
siniestrada muchacho que iba delante mío
me dijo
Mira una casa yo le digo yo lo quedé
mirando desde la avioneta sabes yo fui
corriendo y mire estaba los pedazos
desplomados yo estaba las salas por acá
Había otro pedazo
yo me acerqué tanto y que eso tenía
muchas moscas
estaba lleno
y había muchos Buitres a veces
rondeando el lugar Harvey también nos ha
contado que hasta que no fueron a ver a
sus mayores a los líderes espirituales y
estos pidieron permiso a la selva no
empezaron a mejorar las condiciones
climatológicas y es que este rescate
está teniendo una gran sensibilidad con
las cuestiones indígenas especialmente
por parte del gobierno Y es que la
comitiva la lidera Giovanni Yule un
líder indígena Nasa que es el actual
director de restitución de tierras y
quien se va a establecer en calamar en
la frontera donde inicia la selva para
recibir a indígenas de todo el país y
estamos haciendo un ejercicio de una
minga nacional espiritual porque aquí lo
que vamos a hacer es una conversa con
los Espíritus mayores de la selva vamos
a abrir camino espiritual para que
nuestra madre selva y nuestra madre
naturaleza nos ayude a orientar para
encontrar a los niños que se encuentran
en estos momentos en esos sitios poca
información mucha especulación la última
noticia que tenemos de avances es del
pasado jueves 18 cuando se encontró el
rastro de unas huellas de unos niños que
llevan ya 20 días perdidos en la selva y
que todo el país Espera que sean
encontrados con vida pronto gracias por
su atención hasta que las noticias
[Música]